[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN BELCHER: Boston has
a great heritage for not
only technology,
but specifically,
for technology
related to business
to business and infrastructure.
Stackdriver was founded
in Boston, Massachusetts.
We founded the company in 2012.
It's been really
exciting to watch
Stackdriver grow and evolve.
Now deploying Stackdriver
across Google infrastructure
and taking advantage of
all these exciting Google
technologies, goes
beyond anything
that we could have expected
only two years ago.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN BELCHER: Hi I'm Dan Belcher.
I'm the lead product manager for
operations on the Google Cloud
team.
Prior, I was one of the
founders of Stackdriver.
When we started
Stackdriver, we really
didn't have a specific
product in mind.
Instead, we were
really interested
in the growth in
the public cloud.
And what we did
is we reached out
to hundreds of customers that
were running applications
in the cloud and asked them
what their pain points were.
What we found is that
a lot of customers
had disparate tools for
monitoring the cloud platform,
their systems,
their application,
uptime, and so forth.
And it was really
difficult for them
to not only manage
those systems,
but to look across those systems
to identify and troubleshoot
those issues.
And so when we
built Stackdriver,
we built one service that
brought all those capabilities
together.
PHILIP JACOB: Stackdriver is
a performance and availability
monitoring for public
cloud infrastructure.
So, you connect us to
your cloud infrastructure,
either on Amazon Web Services
or Google Cloud Platform,
and we'll show you
everything that's happening
inside your infrastructure.
We take on the burden of
helping you visualize and run
your application
successfully on the cloud.
Without Stackdriver,
you've got to set up
all kinds of different
tooling, logging, monitoring,
dashboarding.
And we make it really
powerful and simple
and really easy to get started.
ANDRE KELLY: I think Stackdriver
means a lot of excitement when
it comes to reducing the
number of applications one
needs to manage their system.
So being able to bring
that in one place
alleviates a lot of
problems for their ops.
They're able to see how the
entire infrastructure is
performing health-wise
and performance.
We also provide some
great tools that
are industry leading in
terms of being able to do
multi-conditional learning.
So now that you have all the
signals coming in to one place,
you can then tailor alerts to
be very specific to conditions
that you're monitoring
or relate to an incident
that you've received
in the past.
ERIC SILVA: I think
custom metrics
are one of the most interesting
parts of Stackdriver.
As an application
developer, you know
which metrics are the best
indicators of system health.
So you don't want to necessarily
wait for system metrics
like CPU or memory usage
to rise before you're
alerted to a problem.
Using custom metrics,
you can monitor
things that are specific to
your application that give you
an earlier indication
of a problem.
They allow you to
react more quickly
because you know which metrics
are important in your system.
DEEPAK TIWARI: We are also
very excited about some
of the advanced features like
anomaly detection and insights
that we'll bring
to this product.
So people can actually
get proactive insights
on the product rather
than just manually
setting up alerts and
looking at incidents.
I primarily focus on
our logging product.
Our logging product
really is a tool
that we have built
that works at scale
and can look at large
enterprise scale
customers who are
sending us gigabytes
per second scale of logs.
We give them a platform
to visualize those logs.
And we also work
with those customers
to give them more analytics
capabilities on top of the data
so they can make IT ops,
operational, business,
analytical, as well as
security-related decisions,
find them quickly
and take action.
Monitoring, alerting,
incident management,
logging, together
into one place.
What Stackdriver
promises is that it
will make it easier, more
streamlined and faster
to find and fix issues.
PHILIP JACOB:
Stackdriver has always
been about making
operations easier.
For many people running
applications on the cloud,
Stackdriver will
be the only tool
that you need for
monitoring and logging.
You'll have one
interface, one place
to go to help you
identify, troubleshoot,
and resolve issues.
Google acquired Stackdriver
because we share a vision
around creating insight
out of all this data
that we're bringing together.
And so it's good to be
among a larger group that
believes in the same things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]